musikalische meister der stille zu
finden wir haben drei von ihnen
getroffen
musik und stille gehirn zu sammeln
erst einmal weil die musik in von der
definition her wird geboren von der
stille und es gibt auch diese momente wo
mitten im stück eben der musikalische
gedanken nicht aufhört aber die
klangliche das klangliche aufhört und
daher gibt es ein moment kurz oder lang
der stille
ein mensch in seiner agonie liegt wo er
wirklich kurz vor dem sterben ist das
ist wird sehr oft durch die parks
symbolisiert und davor sind natürlich
oft momente der stille oder eines eines
schreckens oder die pauke sozusagen als
schicksals kleinlein kommt das ist
häufig so ohne stelle ohne pause ohne
tatzeit kommt natürlich nicht was gerade
überaus glücklich ist wenn ich zum berg
und noch ansteigen da habe ich die
stelle ich bin irgendwo an und erstelle
ich unter fair news und besuchen die
hose und das sicherlich zum beispiel
vollmer konzert in den konzertsaal die
stille die ruhe bevor man fort das finde
ich viel glück